[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
system is the story of
lalangue when she was a little girl
it's her experience during the war and
the long is a dear friend of mine so I
meant 15 years ago reading her book told
me a lot about this country so in a way
I'm doing this for her for her family
for Cambodia and very much so also
formatic so he learns about who he is
and knows whose people this is the story
of not just my family but the story of a
nation I wasn't going to drop it to
anybody
Audrina por que l'on de las olas a
special-effects a soupy response beyond
official called acoustic emission per
plant aerosol of dango hodong you made
hosea Max has been working on this since
beginning he's in the production he
helped me with the script and it isn't
just because he's my son it's because
this film is through the eyes of a child
and we've all had to open up a little
bit more and be like children I didn't
want to see a child go through war I
wanted to know what a child felt and
what they focused on what they saw
audience chatters important for mitosis
is mr. DiPalma Trevo see mandre -
Mallory tentative destruction region
totally Terra
so no don t TS s mo prettiest excuse me
punk songs canvas Otto the Cambodian
totally sunk about the tree if you know
nothing about Cambodia and you see the
film you won't just think these the
people that suffer through a war you
will think these are really interesting
people their roots and their personality
their humour their love of music their
culture that's all of them it has to be
in the end this love letter to to
Cambodian people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you